the one-eyed giant you know and love has
dominated popular imagination for
thousands of years
the Cyclops combines two monstrous
elements into one a humanoid of massive
stature and a physical malformation that
only rarely occurs in real life the most
famous Cyclops the cannibalistic
Shepherd of the ancient Greek Homeric
myth isn't the only one he's one of many
that turn up not just in Greek mythology
but in other cultures throughout the
world so why is this why a one-eyed
monster in the first place does
paleontology play a part in this to help
us out we asked our friends from eons
for some insight into the possible
origins of this giant food did I mention
only has one eye
I'm dr. Emily szarka and this is monstre
the Cyclops is not a singular creature
that always looks the same or comes from
the same place the word means round die
and can apply to all kinds of monsters
chances are the one you've encountered
is some variation from Homer's famous
taxi Odyssey
the hero Odysseus and his men sailed to
the land of the Cyclops an island home
to a people described as arrogant
lawless folk while exploring the island
they find a remote cave and see a
monstrous man named Polyphemus living
apart from the others tending to his
large flock of sheep in ancient Greece
only primeval or faraway peoples were
attributed to living in caves so those
hearing this tale would know
straightaway that Odysseus was about to
encounter something very different in
the sophisticated Greeks while Polly
famous is away they secretly enter the
monsters came and helped themselves to
the Giants food while waiting for him to
return when the immense Shepherd finally
arrives he seals the door with a huge
stone before spotting the humans when
questioning how they arrived his land
Odysseus lies and tells the creature
their ship crash in a sudden wild fit of
rage Polyphemus snatches two of the men
violently throwing their bodies to the
ground before cutting them limb from
limb while the others watch on in horror
he eats them raw Odysseus and his
friends are understandably horrified and
begin plotting their escape all the
giant sleeps more men are eaten the next
day but Odysseus manages to sharpen a
large steak from the Giants own massive
Club and begins to execute his master
plan of getting Polyphemus drunk with
the wine and full effect the buzzed
giant asks his drinking buddies name
Odysseus responds with nomen while the
giant is asleep Odysseus and four men
hold the stake in a fire until it glows
red hot they thrust this into his eye
blinding the Giant when the other
Cyclops on the island hear his cries of
agony and rush to come see what's wrong
he injured Polly famous can only say he
was hurt by no man the next morning the
now blind giant opens his cave to graze
his sheep and Odysseus and his men
escape clinging beneath the bellies of
the woolly animals as the crew sails
away with some of the giant sheep in tow
I might add belief eNOS hurls massive
rocks at the boat when Odysseus taunts
him legend has it you could even see
these rocks today the unique formation
of the fairy yoni of a cheaper itza are
called the island
of the Cyclops okay I have to say it I
just have to say it Odysseus is actually
a huge I mean the dude goes to this
guy's home eats his cheese steals his
pets and blinds him he's terrible guests
to have I wouldn't want to have him at
my party despite the popularity of this
story Homer never actually says
Polyphemus or any of the other Cyclops
have only one eye it's only assumed from
other events of the story which might be
why a lot of art from ancient Greece
take some artistic liberties and shows
the enormous figure with one two and
even three eyes but there is another
Greek myth with creatures also named
Cyclops who are specifically described
as only having one eye so that author
clearly stole from Homer right well not
exactly
scholars still argue today about which
text came first in his Theogony written
around the same time as homer famous
Greek poet Hesiod tells of a trio of
Smith's these three brothers were said
to be born from the union of the gods
yaeh and Ouranos each with a single eye
in the middle of their foreheads they
are called cyclops after their
appearance each brother is given their
own name and in Greek they translate to
thunder lightning and flash these
one-eyed children of God gifted Zeus
with his Thunderbolt much more
sophisticated and powerful but the
simple violent shepherds of Homer's
story Hesiod details that strength and
might and crafts were in their works
the Cyclops here are portrayed as
blacksmiths and according to an ancient
Greek historian they are even credited
with the invention of bronze weapons
let's think about this association for a
second the ability to forge iron the job
of a blacksmith requires immense
physical strength it's not really hard
to see how such figures would be
considered Giants in mythology
Smith's were important in antiquity but
they were often seen as Outsiders given
that they did not labor in the fields or
hunt like most other people at the time
and if you've watched an episode of this
show before you'll know by now
marginality often equals monstrosity so
whichever story came first
we have two Greek traditions of the
Cyclops one is a society of sheep
herding Giants and the other as one-eyed
children of gods but why Giants with
only one eye in the first place well
there's a pretty popular theory
involving skull fossils now I'm
definitely not a paleontology expert but
luckily for me I do know a few cool ones
Blake could dinosaur bones help explain
to Cyclops myths now according to an
Austrian paleontologist named Athenian
Abel it was elephant fossils not
dinosaur bones that inspired the
original Cyclops myths elephants and
their relatives belong to a group known
as the Provos idiots
and while these amazing animals don't
live in southern Europe today they show
up a lot in the fossil record of the
Mediterranean weather the first species
to arrive in Europe was gumbo theorem a
bizarre mammal with tusks on both its
upper and lower jaws scientists think
gumpa theory and made it to Europe about
eighteen and a half million years ago
and its remains have been found in Spain
and Turkey and it wasn't the last of its
kind to roam the Mediterranean coasts
mammoths mastodons extinct elephants and
a behemoth named Dino theorem lived
there too
Dino theorem whose name means terrible
beast had downward curving tusks
anchored to its chin and did I mention
that it was big like really super duper
big a full-grown Dino theorem stood four
meters tall at the shoulder and may have
tipped the scales at 12 metric tons
making it twice as heavy as a modern
African elephant
but these ancient proba Citians weren't
always giants on Cypress Crete and many
other Mediterranean island's
paleontologists have found remains of
dwarf elephants in Sardinia an island
near Eastern Italy once even had
miniature mammoths and of these smaller
prova Citians among the very smallest
was paleo laksa Don Falconer II standing
no more than 1.2 meters tall and much
like Odysseus's Cyclops its remains are
often found inside of caves on Sicily
and Malta in fact sponaugle OU cave in
southwestern sicily has yielded over
2,000 Dorf elephant bones to date so
what explains these shrunken Giants well
in biology there's a concept called
Foster's rule in a nutshell it states
that on isolated islands the descendants
of small mammals like rats frequently
get larger especially if there's a
lack of predators and the reverse is
often true too when big bodied mammals
like elephants populate an island
natural selection can favor smaller body
sizes because there are fewer resources
bigger small though a proba Citians
skeleton might look downright bizarre to
anybody who's never seen a live elephant
in 1914 Athenian Abel proposed that when
the ancient Greeks came across these
fossils they mistook them for the
remains of one eyed humanoid giants the
reason for the misunderstanding he said
was the one feature that most proba
Citians share the large nasal cavity
high up on the forehead Abel reasoned
that if you saw an elephant skull and
had no idea what its owner looked like
you might not know that this hole had
once been connected to a fleshy trunk
instead you might think it was a single
extra-large eye socket in the middle of
the animals face sound familiar
while giants are present in the midst of
almost all ancient civilizations Homer's
version has dominated in the modern
period variants of the Homeric Cyclops
have been found in France Turkey and
Estonia among other places and there's
even a version in a famous collection of
Arabian folk tales 1001 nights in the
16th century a Turkish manuscript showed
the myth existed outside of Greece in
this version a cyclops like figure
demands to be fed to people and 500
sheep a day he is ultimately defeated
with a spit to the eye and the hero
escapes under the skin of a ram later in
the 19th century Wilhelm Grimm yes he's
one of those brothers published a book
collecting ten folkloric versions of the
blinded ogres story Grimm is widely
considered the first Vallauris to
investigate the various global versions
of homos Polyphemus and the book he
states that all versions of the myth had
ancient origins
maybe those fossils we were talking
about in 1904 German scholar Oscar
Hackman published a collection of 221
versions of the blinding of the ogre
myth taken from 25 different nations
take that brother Grimm the number has
only expanded since then
we still see the Greek versions of the
cyclops myth appearing in literature
class and a few popular instances wrath
of the Titans Disney's Hercules Percy
Jackson and oh brother were Arctic and
today the figure has evolved into
lovable monsters mutant aliens and the
famous x-men character Cyclops you may
have heard them despite these examples
overall the image of the one-eyed giant
as a monster has largely faded if you
take a look at modern visual depictions
of Cyclops they aren't really scary even
the violent cannibals of ancient
mythologies seem laughable now in part
because they are often shown as being oh
fish gullible and well easy to defeat
all you need is a simple plan and a
pointy stick that doesn't exactly
inspire terror but that doesn't mean the
stories about them are any less
significant they show us how modern
paleontology can sometimes help explain
the beliefs of the past and give us a
unique insight into ancient cultures hey
moss from fans thanks for watching if
you haven't done so yet subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all the latest
episodes Aeons is a show produced in
collaboration with PBS Digital Studios
where Hank green Callie Mora and Blake
de pastino take you on a journey through
the history of life on Earth from the
dawn of life in the Archaean Eon through
the Mesozoic era
the so called age of dinosaurs right up
to the end of the most recent Ice Age I
should have done this whole thing with
an eyepatch yes I'm gonna do my rant now
before oh yeah
don'tcha know
[Music]